اخوتي واخواتي الكرام عدنا لكم من جديد
معكم عبود المهم يا اخوان قبل ما نبدا
الفيديو بدي احكي لكم انه اليوم وهو مش
اليوم كل يوم صار سقعه بحسني اني عايش في
موسكو تلج الوضع يعني انا اذا بموت امانه
ما تمسح قال ما تمسحون ما تغسلوني فسحوني
بلنس معطر من كثر ما الجو ساقع يعني ف
انتم المهم يا اخوان اليوم رح نتحدث عن
مركز الاواء واللي يسكنوها الاف المواطنين
في شمال القطاع وفي جنوب القطاع في كل قطع
غزه اللي عنده صف او غرفه في مراكز الاواء
زي اللي عنده روف على البحر فاهمين كيف
اوه انا عندي غرفه تمام هذا اولا ثانيا
اليهود يستهدفها يعني هذه نقطه خطيره انك
تعيش فيها يستهدفها حسوك انه ابو عبيده
عايش فيها لوش تقصفها مش بشره دول ثالثا
ثالثا اه ثالثا انتشار الوباء والامراض
فيها بسبب ازدحام السكان يعني المرض
بينتشر اسرع من كورونا و بتلاقي كل
المدرسه وكل العياده عيانه رابعا الله
يعين ولد بيك وضع تخيل يعني سقعه وحرب
ودمار وحياه بتكون امسه معه الجد الله
يعينا والله يعين كل الشعب وبس والله
السلام
عليكم